votre pire expérience homosexuelle
vous savez que la grand-mère de
Christian Vadim s'appelait hardylouze et
Benoît haute de Verdun a entendu ça la
semaine dernière dans l'émission et il
m'a envoyé un mail avec une idée
d'interview qui s'appelle lardilouze
[Musique]
bon alors dis-nous c'est que des trucs
de loups votre pire passage télé à part
celui-là ce soir c'était quoi mais
c'était le dernier
très bien votre pire cuite jamais avant
j'ai une phobie du vomi donc jamais je
bois pas être malade c'est bien ça c'est
bizarre c'est une chance
et toi c'était quand
ce soir
et vous je vous demande pas c'était la
veille de la demi-finale vous avez vu le
résultat on a vu le résultat bien votre
pire mec Sophie
avec eux on apprendrait que
qu'il a déjà quelqu'un qui m'a caché ça
vous est arrivé ça déjà
la télé non mais très connu
votre pire souvenirs
on se demande qu'est-ce qu'on fout là
quoi c'était comme un salon c'est pas le
salon l'agriculture mais c'était une
femme
il faisait super froid et j'étais au
milieu des vaches et tout ça toute la
journée
on se dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
votre pire expérience homosexuel
votre pire moment avec Geneviève de
Fontenay
c'était en fait on n'était pas ensemble
mais c'est ce qui s'est passé par après
la sortie du livre tout ce qui a été dit
c'était un moment assez dur à vivre le
moment le plus moyen de tout ta carrière
maintenant et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu